we have this story nurse who was forced
to quit her job after being outed as an
only fan star reveals she's earned
millions in just two years as she shows
off lavish spoils from her raunchy
career including two million dollar
mansion designer closet and custom
Porsche she's Ali Ray she's 34. she was
a nurse but she figured out that porn
makes more money and so now she's Rich
she's a millionaire huh well there you
go well well yeah look at that
disgusting now she's an over-educated
porn star I love that is that what they
said the role play well she said she was
literally an RNA the role play the
medical role play could be so great on
her Channel but is that but you know I
don't know if that's overeducated that's
just educated because you know her work
is an exploration of the body and she's
well versed in the human body you know I
like it so what is this what does this
mean for like modern feminist thought
that she was a nurse but she's a
millionaire when she does porn instead
so first of all this tells us that
pushing girls to like educate themselves
is just alive because all you have to do
is go on only fans you can make two
million dollars the other lie here is
that if you do join only fans you will
make two million dollars because this
does not happen 99 plus of the time yeah
what's the average that uh that a woman
gets on only fans it's like what uh I
think it's 60 bucks or 300 bucks a month
on average yeah yeah you just got to be
famous like when we see these stories
about only fans the reality is some
people you've got two people that make
music for some reason someone's music
gets big and everyone listens to it they
make money because of it if you can
attract customers you make money and so
that's really it probably a lot of women
who couldn't do it so you wanna go ahead
remember that one red-headed actress
that like made like a million dollars in
one like overnight or something because
she made it only fans and told her fans
that she was gonna be naked on there but
she really wasn't but she grossed all
this money and it like crashed only fans
isn't that fraud well yeah that's why it
was such a big discussion Bella is
somebody I don't know Delphine yeah
this is this is when you know the market
is getting very saturated and uh look I
can't point fingers saturated my own
yeah okay calm down well I'll remind you
you can make your only fans whatever you
want you can make it a cooking channel
if you want yeah you just it's another
path of uh you know generating income
online it's just another income stream
yeah but we all know technically correct
what it's for yeah let's not kid
ourselves here yeah yeah I feel like
everybody knew when I announced that but
I was like no I'm gonna make like you
know polls about what you want me to
talk about and I'm going to show a
picture of my actual cat who's amazing
and I love him his name you can say you
showed a picture of him that's exactly
what I said I was like here's my cat I
don't think there is someone who does
this they have an only fans and they put
stuff Julie perowski oh issues and it's
like the titles are all suggestive but
then it's just like family friendly yeah
she's reading the Constitution or
something yeah exactly exactly talking
about the First Amendment she's great my
inspiration so that's so that's so
that's it no no no comments on she's not
a nurse anymore
well I I admire her her pay upgrade
because I know nurses don't make that
much but I do think that this really
undercuts the whole case for girls going
even into stem because she actually did
what you're supposed to do and she's
like oh my gosh she's making much money
I'm just starting only fans and then I
think because she didn't only fans and
her co-workers found out she got all
this attention and that gave her the
leverage she needed to turn it into like
a really lucrative lifestyle what you
really want to see is a bunch of these
um e-girls that make all their money and
then they can go into whatever
philanthropic Endeavor they want you
know and go and do great things for
society because they have this career
that's so you know locked in for them
that would be it would almost be
Redemptive it's like so it's like Kim
Kardashian becoming like a civil rights
lawyer like something that she can
contribute that's not so like me
centered it's kind of crazy though but
Kim Kardashian doesn't do this kind of
stuff right she's not like posting porn
well no but I meant I would like to see
that format a lot because once you have
it made on the back of like doing
salacious stuff it's like now you're
free to talk about other things you
could go on and do productive things I
mean Kim Kardashian did get popular from
the coastline
that's why she's famous yeah that's the
only reason she's famous
we had this earlier there's that
politician in New York who made a sex
tape or whatever oh yeah that's gross
hey man you know the time's there are
changing are we gonna watch it yeah
we're gonna play it for the audience
live to review it let's review it that's
for the members only yeah the members
it's gonna be like mystery signs Theater
3000 or whatever yes where you can see
the back of our heads as we watch this
stuff yeah yeah
well there you go they should make a
video about how they're going to screw
the taxpayer in an actual score this is
ever going to screw you buddy
that'd be great take it I love it
I could say a lot I could say a lot more
and I have a lot more parts but this is
a family-friendly show and I'm a
professional
does Nancy Pelosi's daughter
oh man
yeah what's Nancy Pelosi's daughter look
like oh let's find out who is her dog
what else I remember hearing about her a
couple of times didn't she work with Jon
Stewart or The Daily Show or something
like that I don't know but she's or is
that Hillary Clinton yeah
she looks like Nancy Pelosi goodness
trying to find like a bigger picture I
guess they're all like really small not
great wow large Nancy Pelosi daughter
uh there you go is that one oh that's a
big one
that's a viewable photo there you go
all right she's taller humans have
gotten a lot taller look how much
different Nancy looks
yeah well you know that's a lot of
plastic surgery this is uh a lot of
people don't know this but um palanci uh
Pelosi
Pelosi actually had a a guest role in an
HBO TV show uh actually it was a long
running TV show it's called Tales from
the Crypt
there's a joke because I called it the
Crypt Keeper she doesn't like that to be
fair yeah she was very cute when she was
younger oh wait wait wait you know how
you do the Deep fake stuff oh can
someone deep fake her face under the
Crypt Keeper popping out of things
that would be great someone do that and
tweet it
yeah maybe it does exist I'm sure that
would be fantastic her daughter is not
very pretty
we're Power Tour I guess for being a
lawyer are you saying she shouldn't do
only fans I don't think anyone should
use only fans for the purpose that it's
fingers and put you in whatever role in
Society you want to be I mean honestly
that's a free ticket to anywhere you
want to go no I don't know like if I got
a call from Pelosi and she was like have
I want my daughter on your show I'd be
like no why yeah but there's a thousand
of you I mean no offense I'm just saying
they'll find some other person that put
her on the show that does well no I know
it's just like but they're still pigeon
hold I suppose if she wanted her to be
like a manager at a chicken processing
plant she could do it she's not too bad
don't be hating Linda so to be fair we
already know we know that women judge
other people very harshly like we've
seen the graphs about how they rate men
on dating sites right I think this this
transfers to other women as well just
from my personal experience for sure oh
and she's look look at the picture of
from Wikipedia she's holding a camera
it's so that you know that she makes
movies she looks good for a 52 year old
lady is she 52. yeah oh my leg wow
that's crazy she does look pretty good
that's her yeah for 52. so wait is
Christy oh she looks more like Nancy
there we go yeah
and she's not the one who's making
movies it's the other one okay there's
two is there like Laura and Christina I
don't know oh she produces documentaries
for uh her mother American selfie man
you know wow it must I just can't
imagine being part of a legacy family
like that I feel like it would suck
she's gonna win Oscars soon I mean
that's how all these peoples like are
built over time like we were talking
about CNN earlier and it reminded me how
when I was a kid in public schools they
had us watch uh channel one and Andrew
Anderson Cooper was like a young
journalist and that was like his first
gig so like if you're like a Vanderbilt
they just install you and like and see
how it was just like set up for Anderson
Cooper to be well you know after you
interned for the CIA yeah a little bit
Yeah Yeah but all of that stuff that's
just what I mean there's a different
level of access for these people that
are operating above everybody else it's
like whatever your child wants to be you
just you know give it to them on a
silver platter and hope that they don't
screw it up because nothing has any
value to them because they can have
whatever they want first they go to the
top schools where all the professors are
afraid to give them a low grade then
they intern at the Central Intelligence
Agency see then they again just you know
get a lucrative job that of course
everyone dreams of getting but it's
actually nepotism to the highest level
yeah think about the long-term priming
of that like taxpayers funded me as a as
a child to be exposed to Anderson Cooper
who would later be like the face of you
know the most trusted name in news I
mean that's that's a kind of like
unconscious priming of like making these
people celebrities so I don't think that
we should close this conversation about
the Pelosi Offspring without mentioning
Paul Jr because apparently in August
2022 suspicions were raised over
authorities Financial ties with
pelosi-led U.S delegation and that
included her son Paul Jr so there's that
that there's that bidenesque corruption
so it's everywhere well see this is easy
for me to see because I live in
Hollywood and I've done entertainment
for like I don't know the 13 years or
something so like that I just watch I
just watch these like highlighted veins
of access to everything all the time and
seeing it in politics is is no different
well there it is
nepotism
I was I had a joke
that was going to lay up a layup for
Luke but I can't say it because you know
it shows family I have to I have to
censor 20 like 75 of everything I want
to say on this show yeah y'all keep
saying this is a family-friendly show
you
I didn't swear a little bit just a bit
yeah I did I I didn't know that was uh
one of the cardinal sins of yeah you
could never come back that's it it's not
that big families and friends the
chickens will attack you on your way out
it's true yeah yeah Chris is preparing
them right now it's true
I've been wanting to see uh chicken City
from the inside thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there